from giant monsters to MCU characters
our list is growing every day and or
every couple of days
Godzilla Titans and guides you dominate
the world of sizes and gigantic
proportions but in this list we are
going to take out Toho most of us or any
Japanese guide you including the Pacific
Rim creatures so here is a list of the
seven largest sea monsters seen in
movies
number one the Megalodon from the Meg
the Meg also known as the Megalodon are
the main antagonists of underwater
chiller novel series of the same name
and also of the 2018 movie megalodons
appear to be huge shops with massive
mouths and lot sharp teeth they appear
to be much larger than regular sharks
measuring over 20 to 25 meters the Meg
was accidentally released from the
Mariana Trench by Jonas Taylor who was
examining the wreck of a submarine the
crew eventually comes to the conclusion
that a shark that attacked them was a
Megalodon a prehistoric shark that
became extinct 2 million years ago
number 2 of Talas from deep rising up
talus is the main antagonist in the 1998
horror film deep rising it is a huge sea
creature of unknown origin which eats
every passenger and crew member of the
luxury cruise ship argonautica on which
the film mostly takes place after lists
could be hundreds of years old as
everybody say sunken ships on the ground
of the ocean at the beginning of the
movie which are often different
centuries of mankind optimises body
consists of many long slimy tentacles
with mouths on the end of them and a
body with a big mouth and two eyes the
tentacles can also close their mouths
and are arguably one of the most
fascinating parts of the dangerous sea
monster it is unknown if the tentacles
act on their own to serve the main body
or if oculus has full control over them
number three
Kraken from Pirates of the Caribbean the
Kraken was a legendary sea monster
elevate and send to prey on unwary ships
and Mariners a fearsome creature with
tentacles closely resembling that of a
giant squid the Kraken was said to be
the length of 10 ships
few had seen the Kraken and lived to
tell the tale the word Kraken was first
heard in seagoing lore and mythology
before
to a sea creature whose many arms or
tentacles could reach to the top of his
ships main mast and could without any
great effort capsize a fully rigged
vessel the huge suckers on the Krakens
tentacles was strong enough to pull the
flesh clean away from sailors face after
becoming a mock man with a black spot
ensuring that the Kraken would come
Captain Jack Sparrow attempted to find a
Dead Man's Chest which contained the
heart of Davy Jones and Jack plan to use
too hard to make Jones call off the
Kraken number 4 Kraken from Clash of the
Titans the Kraken in Greek mythology is
a giant sea monster of tremendous size
and strength he appears as the final
antagonist in the 1981 film Clash of the
Titans and his 2010 remake he was born
from the Titans name Oceanos and seto
both entities of the sea his height is
around 300 feet or 90 plus mirrors his
tentacles are large enough to be able to
pull in giant ships on the dewater and
destroy cities with relative ease the
Kraken appears in 2010 remake as an
adversary of Perseus although this
iteration of the monster is female the
Kraken is seen in the beginning when the
narrator explains Hades created her to
slay the Titans number 5 keratin of
Aquaman
the keratin is a colossal sentient sea
creature and one of the oldest and most
powerful beings on earth she has guarded
the Trident of Appling in the hidden sea
for millennia and later assists Aquaman
with his quest to prevent war between
the surface world and sea fighting on
his side against ocean master in the war
for Atlantis long for to be merely a
creature of legend many Atlanteans
believe that the keratin served as a
guarding piece of the ocean who would
one day rise up from the depths to
signal Atlantis's up rising from its
watery exile in truth however she is
very real having been found deep within
a pit behind a waterfall and hidden see
the keratin resembles a colossus
combination of a squid a shrimp and a
dragon and is maybe between 300 and 400
feet tall or between 90 and 120 meters
in height
number 6 characters of Percy Jackson the
Sea of Monsters characters was once a
beautiful giantess the daughter of
Poseidon and Gaia
she takes the form of a huge mouth that
swallows great amounts of water and
debris three times a day creating
multiple
cooze when Percy Annabeth and Dyson
arrived in the Sea of Monsters they are
instantly sucked in by characters Percy
tried to use the water to drag them away
from her but his water powers had no
effect soon after they enter her stomach
which contained all the ships that went
missing in the Bermuda Triangle as well
as Clarisse and has Amba crew above the
CSS Birmingham the group managed to
escape when Percy fired the main gun at
her stomach before they were completely
digested the amount of characters is
surrounded by mist smoke and water
she anchors herself to a black reef with
a small fig tree on top characters has
slimy lips and mossy teeth each tooth
being about the size of a rowboat so
it's easy to say that she has hundreds
of meters in size number 7 Glover from
Cloverfield and Cloverfield paradox
clover is the given name of an
underwater life form that appears in
Cloverfield and Cloverfield paradox the
monster rampages throughout Manhattan
destroying the city in a spark the
destruction causes the United States
government to sacrifice New York City in
an attempt to give the monster with
heavy ornaments in the hammer down
protocol the monster is a 240 to 300
foot high quadruped it with long dry
fork fin tail however in the third
installment of the Cloverfield franchise
Cloverfield paradox at the end of the
movie the club of monster was seen yet
again but in this movie the monster
towered over the clouds while it was
standing in a place that was a part of
the ocean many fan estimates give the
Glover at 5 to 6 kilometers tall or tree
to 4 miles in height so this comes
together the lists do like share and
subscribe for more videos about monsters
guides you and all those good stuff